All right, let's get the big boy.
This is a new one.
Yep.
Here it comes.
Oh, boy.
Holy.
I mean, come on.
What?
Come on.
It's just too.
It's too good.
It's too massive.
I can't even handle it.
Oh, my God.
Look at this.
This is my hand.
And this is Korea.
Oh, man.
Let's get the Soviet energy map.
Soviet.
Energy.
Map.
I don't read this, but I think this is like...
I don't know.
I'm actually not even going to opine on what
it is.
Because I don't actually know.
I know it has something to do with the energy
needs of the U.S.
I think it's energy production, maybe?
Maybe it's like, I don't know, some resources.
Somebody tell me what this is.
Freaking gorgeous.
I've been obsessed with maps my whole life
and never thought I'd have a day where I could
just put up a map in my studio and just look
at it and just have it as big as me.